nos dicen el polinomio pd x igual a 4 x
al cubo más 19 x cuadrada más 19 x menos
6 tiene un factor conocido x + 2
reescribe pd x como un producto de
factores lineales pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo
vamos a resolverlos juntos si no nos
hubieran dado esta parte de la
información que dice que tiene un factor
conocido x más 2 este polinomio no sería
tan sencillo de factorizar pero debido a
que sabemos que existe este factor
conocido x + 2 podemos usarlo para
dividir esta expresión y ver si podemos
factorizar el resultado vamos a hacerlo
vamos a usar x + 2 para dividir el
polinomio 4x al cubo más 19 x cuadrada
más 19 x menos 6 y esto ya lo hemos
hecho varias veces nos preguntamos
cuántas veces cabe x en 4x al cubo cabe
4 x al cuadrado que escribimos en la
columna de segundo grado
4 x cuadrada por x es 4 x al cubo 4 x
cuadrada x 2 es 8 x cuadrada ahora
arrestamos esto de acá y nos queda 19 x
cuadrada menos 8 x cuadrada es igual a
11 x cuadrada bajamos el 19 x + 19 x y
ahora vemos cuántas veces cabe x en 11 x
cuadrada cabe 11 x veces aquí ponemos
más 11 x 11 x x x es 11 x cuadrada 11 x
x 2 es 22 x restamos esto de lo que está
en verde y nos queda 19 de algo menos 22
negativo de ese algo es igual a menos 3
de ese algo en este caso es menos 3 x
ahora bajamos al menos 6 y nuevamente
vemos cuántas veces cabe x en menos 3x y
cabe menos tres menos tres por x es
menos 3x y menos 3 por 2 es menos 6 y
como queremos restar
lo que está en rojo de lo que está en
magenta multiplicamos ambos por negativo
todo se cancela y no queda residuo
podemos reescribir px como igual a x2
por todo esto 4x cuadrada más 11 x menos
3 aún no terminamos porque no lo hemos
expresado como producto de factores
lineales esto de aquí es lineal pero 4x
cuadrada más 11 x menos 3 no lo es a una
escuadra tica por lo que tenemos que
seguir factor izando y hay un par de
formas con las que podemos resolver esto
podemos tratar de aplicar la fórmula
cuadrática o podemos factorizar por
agrupación para factorizar por
agrupación sólo necesitamos un
coeficiente principal que no sea 1 y
queremos pensar en dos números cuyo
producto sea 4 x menos 3 los llamaremos
a y de a por b debe ser igual a 4 x
menos 3 que es menos 12
debe ser igual a 11 y solo se me ocurre
que tienen que ser de signos opuestos
porque el producto es negativo puede ser
12 y 1 negativo es menos 1 y b es 12
esto podría funcionar ahora lo que
quiero hacer es tomar este término de
primer grado 11 x y separarlo en 12 x y
menos una x vamos a hacerlo y nos vamos
a enfocar en esta parte de aquí por
ahora después lo volveremos a juntar
todo al final puedo reescribir esto como
4x cuadrada y en lugar de escribir 11 x
que resalto en azul lo separo como 12 x
y menos una x noten que al sumar ambos
es igual a 11 x y después ponemos menos
3 veamos de estos dos primeros que puedo
factorizar puedo factorizar 4x y si no
están familiarizados con lo que estoy
haciendo los invito a que revisen la
factorización por agrupación en khan
academy factor izamos 4x y nos queda
x 3 y de los otros dos términos
puedo factorizar el menos 1 si lo
hacemos queda menos 1 por x 3 luego
factor izamos los x + 3 me estoy
quedando sin colores y nos queda x + 3 x
4 x voy a mantener los mismos colores
para que se note de donde salieron estos
números 4 x menos 1 nos está quedando
una solución muy colorida ya factor hice
la segunda parte en estos dos factores y
ahora puedo juntar todo reescribimos pd
x como un producto de factores lineales
es igual a x2 x x 3 x 4 x menos 1 y con
esto terminamos